although life is getting back to normal
for most Brits and others members of the
Commonwealth now for the Royals they're
still in mourning yes it is it goes on
for until next Monday and I'm pleased
actually because the amount of energy
and where they went and the the mix of
emotion and a desperation to get to the
people and to make sure that you're
going to be popular I think he's
enormously exhausting so I think but
Prince Charles of course pitched Charles
King Charles I wish I had a plan for
every time I've done that yeah
um he's the last person to want to relax
or take it easy I mean he's a workaholic
a mother had I mean he worked every
single day of the year and often till
2am when he falls asleep on his laptop
um but I think this time
um Camilla our new Queen she will
actually encourage him to go on walks
that's a very good way of him unwinding
and it's very beautiful up in Scotland
where he is and um he can actually take
a bit of a breather I hope there'll be
lots of um work that he has to do
paperwork and things and that will
continue but it's just that he will have
some peace for the two of them and just
all can be together they make each other
laugh and I think that's always very
relaxing and Camilla said quite recently
that what they really like is to be up
in birkwell in in Scotland and not
necessarily even talk to each other but
sit close by reading or looking at
papers and and just letting strain sort
of
yeah what are his sons
well
um I think Harry's going back to other
they said they were going back straight
after the funeral but um there's not not
quite sure whether this is oh well I
think that I never thought that would
work you couldn't do that because Harry
doesn't want to
um he wants his waiting for William to
apologize and I'm not quite sure why he
wants him to apologize he says because
he didn't support me when I needed it
well I think Harry has been much worse
in what he said about William than
William
um actually not being able to drop
everything the moment he wants it
compromise is very important about this
isn't understanding the other person has
a view but Harry doesn't want to
compromise William did I mean invited
him to go around and talk to people at
Windsor look at the flowers go for a
walkabout but you know they've been
looking there's been complaints about
how they've been treated Petty
complaints and totally inappropriate
time and I can't see that they should
actually complain during this week since
when the Queen's death and her funeral
should have been allowed to wear his
uniform though shouldn't he I mean he
did have two tours of Afghanistan yes
but I think that's pretty Petty as well
he is here he did wear uniform when he
was supposed to be guarding the queen
but then he made a big fuss that he
didn't have her name on the on the top e
to R but he didn't have it when he got
married I there were pictures of him
wearing the same outfit when he got
married he didn't have it then I mean I
think they look for things that are not
quite right and make a huge fuss about
it I'm sorry I really I mean I and I can
tell when I did his biography in 2018 he
was absolutely a delicious person and
very in in understanding of people
damaged
yes that's what I mean it I think I
think they were all very awkward with
each other
you can't get rid of such terrible
wounds personal wounds in in a minute
you've got to have a lot of time to be
able to talk about it and discuss it but
of course they can't trust Harry or
Megan because they leak things to you
know papers and television and
documentaries so it's very difficult you
can't trust that it would be a secret
and private
um
if you see Megan she pushes her hair
over the front every single time she
sees somebody she was very awkward on
this she kept them waiting 45 minutes
while she changed my invited her she was
45 minutes late which I thought was a
bit rude
um final thought about the King when he
comes back he'll come back to London
what will he do
well he'll do all his papers he will
start planning of all the things that he
wants to do he will think about
comparing himself to what his mother did
and how he can take that forward and I
think that means that he will actually
be much more accessible to the public we
saw that when he came back after the her
Queen's death instead of going straight
into Buckingham Palace exhausted and
worn out emotionally he came out shook
hands with everybody very generous and I
think that
um it was I'm with you please be with me
type of thing okay and I think that's
very good I think he was he won't take
it quickly he'll do it slowly and
thinking about it carefully